يدخلون العسكر هذا خلال بالنظام في جلسه
عاصفه استمرت حتى الفجر شهدت اعتراض
وانسحاب الكتل البرلمانيه المستقله صوت
البرلمان العراقي على تعديل قانون
الانتخابات تعديل وصفته القوى المعارضه
بانه تكريس لسيطره الاحزاب الكبيره على
الدوره المقبله للبرلمان وتغييب للتيارات
الديمقراطيه المستقله تمرير قانون مرفوض
حقيقه من قبل الشعب ومن قبل المرجعيه هو
تمرد على الشعب حقيقه من صوت على ستكون
بدايه النهايه له اذا الشعب يوما اراد
الحياه فلابد ان يستجيب القدر هنا قدرنا
ان نذهب معارضه وطنيه واعيه حقيقيه ما هي
ابرز التعديلات التي اجريت على قانون
الانتخابات العوده الى قانون 2018 الذي
رفضته حركه تشرين الاحتجاجيه عام 2019 كل
محافظه ستعد دائره انتخابيه واحده اي 18
دائره بدلا من 83 دائره التي اعتمدت في
الانتخابات الاخيره التعديلات الجديده تصب
في صالح القوى السياسيه الكبيره ولا تمنح
المستقلين فرصه في المنافسه اعاده تحديث
سجل الناخبين في كركوك بعد تسويه بين
قومياتها العربيه والتركمانيه والكرديه
اعاده العمل بالعد والفرز اليدوي تعديل
قانون الانتخابات والتصويت عليه بهذه
الصيغه ما كان ليتم لولا وجود اتفاق بين
القوى السياسيه الشيعيه والسنيه والكرديه
حينما استقرت كل هذه الفتره
واحكمت قبضتها على المشهد السياسي لم تكن
من فراغ بالاتت من اتفاق سياسي اهداء لا
تكوين اداره الدوله وبالتالي تكوين
الحكومه وهذا هو ما ادى اليوم الى نيمار
القرن بهذه الاريحيه بغياب التيار الصدري
وربما معارضه الاحزاب المستقله والصغيره
اقر البرلمان العراقي تعديل قانون
الانتخابات الذي ستجرى بموج به الانتخابات
المحليه المتوقعه في نوفمبر المقبل من
بغداد منتظر رشيد العربيه